if a man cat called me I'd be able to
make him feel menstrual cramps
immediately today I'm going to create my
own superpower to deal with cat callers
kick in the face because it's EKGs when
I did that did you catcalling has been
going on ever since I came up at womb it
would usually be teenage boys when I was
a teenager so at the time I kind of took
it as flattering but then as I got older
and realized they would literally cat
call anything that moved a construction
worker said look at the tits on that I
even remember what I was wearing the
first time I got cat called I was 12 and
I didn't understand that you couldn't
wear a denim jacket as an actual top
look at the kids on her you know what I
mean like it's like you're objectifying
my boobs but then you're also
objectifying the rest of me it's always
the dustiest dude it's always the guy
who has like they ketchup stain on his
white teeth they have cat calls down for
regular women but then when they see a
pregnant woman there is where--this
surprise like whoa whoa Wow well there's
a lady with something in her I want to
put my dick in her when they can't call
me they try to be polite like well uh
you got nice ankles I can see those
think those are very moisturized ankles
I see you I'm not here for any guy that
tells me to smile like my face is always
resting whenever a guy tries the cat
call me I would teleport his mother to
the scene of the crime because I would
like to say could you can't call me in
front of your mother when I got cat
calls me I could make myself invisible
just whispering objectifying things in
his ear and slowly drive him anything my
superpower would be making their pants
disappear I would fart on command I know
some people say they can actually fart
on command
I am not capable of that if a man can't
called me I'd be able to make him feel
menstrual cramps immediately not only is
it gonna smell it's also gonna sting the
eyes I think it would sort of have a
similar effect to pepper spray oh my
hair what you're into snakes as soon as
somebody can't call me the biggest snake
what it is head and there's
not even to stay there looking at your
body makes me so hungry and I just want
to eat you like you were a burrito
hello mrs. Jackson do you know your son
with cat calling me today he said I had
a fat ass here every pants on does he
usually still talk like that in front of
you miss Jackson do what have a fat ass
look at your body you like my ass how
about now
[Music]
does your dick hurt now I bet you also
have diarrhea are you honest about that
that you have diarrhea your period why
don't you smile women had superpowers
and could use it against cat callers
it'd be a completely different world
most of the time I usually want to meet
these guys mothers anyway because I'm
like who raised you to cat call at 2:00
p.m. on a Monday it sounds great to have
snakes coming out of my hair I don't
even like snakes but if I don't have to
see them and they do all the work for me
then I love snakes evolution wise men
would like find a way to get past the
superpowers they might stop cat calling
out of fear but probably not